the argument that I am advancing is that
the Democratic Party is corrupt this is
not a secret its corruption is centered
in the DNC also not a secret and that
that entity serves the true constituents
of the modern Democratic Party which are
special interests that fuel that cabal
so in order to serve those interests the
the party cannot embrace the interests
of working-class people right that is
antithetical to their corruption their
corruption involves parasitizing
working-class people so how do you keep
working-class people from rebelling
against the corrupt entity well you
point them at somebody else and in this
case maybe you even point them at
somebody else from whom they might be
able to extract well-being in order to
distract them from where opportunity
really concentrated at the top amongst
rent-seeking elites so there is a game
afoot to partner with this movement in
order to deflect attention from the real
problem on to some fictional version of
the problem that fictional version of
the problem being some kind of white
supremacy that is ubiquitous inside
white minds and will never be gone right
that's nonsense of course
but it is the alternative story to the
true story of where the well-being went
now at Evergreen we had a president who
for whatever reason wanted to increase
his power and consolidate it and he made
many moves to do so basically he
structured an administration to insulate
him from blame and to protect him from
being eliminated and to allow him to
advance the ball he became effectively
like you know a dictator relative to the
college and so he cynically partnered
with the protesters who became rioters
so quickly at Evergreen and in so doing
he did advance the ball he is going to
now retire at the end of his contract
with commendations on his is a bravery
and wisdom like brave there are no
characteristics on which he scores lower
than those two and he's gets like I'm
sorry bravery and wisdom
bravery and wisdom so he is gonna retire
at the end of his contract he's actually
gonna be allowed to teach at Evergreen
at a time when we're you know mean this
just doesn't make any sense relative to
the story so he made it he's succeeded
in advancing his own ball he made three
hundred thousand dollars a year at the
head of this college but the college
isn't gonna survive it so the point is
the DNC is protecting itself it's gonna
partner with this ideology this ideology
is truly going to wreck the Republic and
frankly it's not even gonna get the
chance to which is something we should
talk about because if you just let the
DNC go and there was no other force out
there then yes okay they would unhook
all of the protections America would
become a race First Nation in which we
prioritized everything intersectionally
but we're not going to get there because
you have a large well-armed white
population that now has an actual reason
to fear what comes next
and that is going to boil over into
mayhem very very soon
[Music]